l'ambiance était pourtant là et les
supporters aussi oddateee à voisins le
bretonneux
le public était présent pour ce dernier
grand rendez vous de l'euro 2016
pour cette finale qui opposait la france
au portugal ont cessé yémen à certains
pronostics peut être un peu trop
optimistes trois pour la france 3 0
pas le temps pas le temps de nantes 3-0
alors deux griezmann et en paillettes au
coup sur coup franc 3 0 comme en 98 et 2
et 3 0 des buts qui ne viendront pas
pendant cette première période plusieurs
occasions côté français et même une
sortie sur blessure de cristiano ronaldo
star de cette équipe portugaise les
équipes rentreront aux vestiaires sur un
score vierge qui n'égratigne pourtant
pas le moral des supers un peu déçu bien
sûr que la panthère a marqué on a
concrétisé on n'a rien concrétisé
malheureusement mais ça va venir
seraient toujours en seconde mi-temps le
bretonneux ambiance cinéma le stade
pierre de coubertin transformé pour
l'occasion en fan zones locales les deux
équipes iront en prolongation jusqu'au
but portugais
pour les spectateurs français c'est la
douche froide
c'est gratuit et comme tout le monde oui
on était persuadés qu'ils allaient le
faire mais dommage de passer à côté
déçu et puis c'est tout
ouah manque de chance c'est tout c'est
mon but très beau but mais
on est français était pas là bravo aux
portugais on va rien dire d'autre
c'est nous que m